[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
[Music]
what a [ __ ] loser
[Music]
teen counts guilt in a criminal trial
Trump organization
okay now do the individuals
17 counts 17 not seven not three
not five 17 counts guilty
in a court criminal criminal court
yesterday I've been telling this for a
long time that Trump is a criminal and
yesterday it's confirmed now people are
like oh well they didn't try him they
only tried his business and Alan
weiserberg blah blah yakety schmackity
listen
Alan weiselberg said in open court that
Donald Trump knew of these frauds and
other folks at the Trump organization
knew of these frauds that is how the
Trump organization was found guilty of
these 17 crimes crimes
it was a criminal court not a civil
court now the ongoing uh civil
litigation is going to take place
through the Attorney General's office on
the Trump organization which is in
receivership by the way now they got to
pay a big huge fine not big enough of
course
my guess is though because the Manhattan
DA's hired some new attorneys and
prosecutors
um that has dealt with Trump and his
Charities before my guess is though
is that some of these
um counts of fraud are going to be
referred if not already to the sdny the
feds now
we also know speaking of referrals to
the feds
we announced here yesterday as the news
broke that the January 6 select
committee is going to be referring
criminal charges to the Department of
Justice now because it has to do with
January 6th my guess is
Jack Smith's gonna get a hold of that
did you know that Jack Smith
prosecutes war criminals oh [ __ ] that's
got to be a [ __ ] I'm I'll tell
you I would of all prosecutors in the
entire world that I would want crawling
up my ass and living there for quite
some period of time and rustling around
in my business
someone who [ __ ] prosecutes war
criminals would not be my first choice
not my first choice
also in other losses in in Trump's orbit
is that
there's this guy hey it used to be a
Heisman Trophy winner used to be
he's a husband
and now he's really a has been
how in the I you know the thing that
really astonishes me I I wasn't
surprised Warnock won
Warnock really won the popular vote
in the midterm but you know in Georgia
they had this runoff thing where if you
don't get 50 it's an automatic thing
just that's just how they do the law
there it's how they do their elections
every state kind of gets to do their own
little thing
you know
and and so I'm not surprised that we're
not one there just was not enough energy
and not enough votes
for Walker to pull this out just it just
wasn't
and we just needed the turnout
is the key
and it's obvious now more than ever what
is motivating voters to elect
politicians
it's voting against
fascism it's voting against the America
First Nazi party trumpism
it's voting against that
did you know they they didn't win one of
our incumbent seats not one
there was supposed to be a big red wave
they we held on to every single
incumbent every [ __ ] one of them in
the Senate every one of them
even in Georgia
and if you really think about the
Georgia race because Warnock is a is a
very decent senator
there's no history in his record in the
last few years of being the incumbent
senator from the special election that
would make you question
rather he's a competent senator now you
may disagree like on his policies and
his votes
but he's coherent
foreign
around talking about werewolves and
vampires okay
but here's the thing
if the Republican Party would have ran
a coherent
decent candidate in Georgia it's
possible we'd still be at a 50 50 Mark
right now
it's a possibility
if someone like Brian Kemp
are Brad rathisberger would have ran for
the senate seat in Georgia that arm of
the party the anti-trump arm in Georgia
because there is a strong anti-trump
arm in Georgia folks there's a strong in
the Republican party that is a huge
wedge that we need to draw
as we politicize
these these 20 22 midterms because we
need to politicize him and we need to
draw the wedges between the American
verse Nazi party
and what we would consider your
grandpa's Republicans which Kemp is not
your grandpa's Republican either
he just doesn't want to go to prison for
Trump
in that in that kind of a weird bar
right that's a weird [ __ ] bar like
2020 the bar for president was just just
decency right what a low [ __ ] bar
that is decency whoosh now
in Georgia the bar is
are are you gonna go to prison for Trump
because really if you look at what is
going to happen over the next few years
there is going to be hundreds
hundreds possibly more than a thousand
people go to [ __ ] prison for Donald
Trump
are you listening to the words I'm
saying now he's probably going to end up
indicted and jailed as well but listen
to the words I'm saying
within within the next few years
there is going to be
indicted convicted
jailed incarcerated
possibly over a thousand
people
because they were acting on the best
of Donald Trump
not even Ronald Reagan doesn't
hold a [ __ ] candle to that not even
[ __ ] close and Ronald Reagan's
Administration was a criminal [ __ ]
organ Administration I don't know if you
Dunning looking into it and I'm not
going to go into details today but just
go do a quick Google search of how many
people and the people that were
criminally charged that were in
around the Reagan Administration whoosh
Donald Trump
is not gonna lose in that category he's
definitely going to win that prize
of the most people
who were convicted jailed and
incarcerated because they were acting on
the behest of him
uh we know that there's a grand jury in
DC
um I think it's the most significant
grand jury and then we've been talking
about it here on the show because
um everyone really put the January 6th
investigation into the coup the Cheeto
dust kangaroo coup
and the documents case where he stole
our property the government ours the We
the People
for whatever reason right we we viewed
those as two separate things
I believe that we are going to find out
that those are not two separate things
right I mean there's a lot of you know
outline Fringe crime when you're talking
about January 6 and you're talking about
this documents case
in other words the document's case
he was stealing stuff that didn't have
anything to do with January 6 but he
stole it and then he obstructed to give
it back
and now he's he's probably still
obstructing and still holding some of
that information
but we know from the January 6th select
committee that there was missing
documents from the White House that
they'd requested hmm seems kind of weird
that there's missing documents that the
January 6th select committee found
relevant to their investigation into the
Cheeto dust kangaroo coup
and the Cheeto does cue in honor just
happens to steal a bunch of I don't know
documents from the White House hmm it
seems as if those two things have a
shitload to do with each other
and they do
they do
absolutely you could not convince me
otherwise and I guess we'll see
maybe in an open court
right
but some more outliers on the January 6
investigation that Jack Smith has taken
over
is this state elector scheme we we found
out yesterday I didn't I didn't show it
on the show
um
subpoenas are reigning
so it's a subpoena storm I don't know if
this is what Q Anon was talking about
the storm is coming like Jack Smith is
the [ __ ] storm or what I'm not really
sure and speaking of Q Anon this is
hilarious this is this is where you mock
these [ __ ] boneheads
the minute
the minute Trump organization was found
guilty on 17 counts
of criminal fraud
and and crime in New York
with the Manhattan D.A DA's office
prosecuting
within moments I guess
the largest part of Q anon on the
internet went 17
what's the 17th letter of the alphabet q
and then just uh you know they're
[ __ ] they had to go get the lotion
and the tissue
you know because they can't oh they can
they can't help but jerk off to these
[ __ ]
that's queuing on stuff
and yesterday Grandpa poopy pants which
I'm sure he needed plenty of diapers
yesterday after a lot that is going on
around him not only can he not get a
Senate candidate off the ground
in Georgia
he he loses in New York with 17 counts
of criminal charges guilty
now Jack Smith is again
bringing the subpoena storm to these
states in the state elector scheme I've
been telling you this state elector
scheme
is a wild part just just a part of the
coup if you if you followed our coverage
on the Midas touch Network for the
January 6 select committees that I
hosted me and Gabe Sanchez hosted here
at the donut Michaels podcast you will
know that there were many legs of the
coup attempt it was not just he was
going to incite violence at the Capitol
that was one of his last straw moves
we've seen that in the Stuart Rhodes
oathkeeper trial
that martial law was going to be enacted
they were going to use the Insurrection
act and they were going to be Patriots
or whatever the [ __ ] kind of delusional
[ __ ] that they
were justifying their sedition with
but the state elector scheme is one of
the largest
probably the most provable parts of the
Cheeto dust kangaroo coup
and the reason why is because there's a
shitload of organization and and
communication that would had to have
happened
for that to get off the ground
I mean just alone in the January 6
select committee when Mike Pence and his
his staff was trying to figure out if
they could stall to get other electors
if that's a thing they can do
just think about the communication that
they were that they were undergoing
and and that we see the evidence of
this is not
the evidence that Jack Smith is now
looking for
he's now looking for communications
for that state elector scheme to Trump's
team in and of itself
this is very bad for Trump it's very bad
for Trump's team uh John Eastman Ruth
Giuliani
Jeffrey Clark speaking of Rudy
speaking
of old grandpa farty mcsharty Rudy
Giuliani Rudy kaluti
apparently yesterday
you know he's losing his law license
there was a hearing he he was wearing
two watches we showed that
um clip [ __ ] didn't even know he
had two watches on but apparently
he did not have any evidence it just
there was no evidence it was all
[ __ ]
um he's trying to trying to get back his
law license he's proud hopefully he will
not but
um I think we're gonna see these [ __ ]
flip and you already have the White
House legal staff
going and testifying before this grand
jury in DC about the state elector
scheme
and it doesn't help it doesn't help that
the other leg
of the coup attempt the violent part of
the coup attempt
with with one part of it with the Oath
Keepers
has already been tried with a jury and
convicted
of seditious conspiracy of sedition
I mean I I don't know exactly what the
sentences is going to be for Stuart
Rhodes I I would I mean I can only guess
what a judge is going to do
and that as far as you know what the
sentencing is going to be the
prosecution is going to bring I mean
there's guidelines so they do like a
[ __ ] math thing right and they figure
out what the guidelines say
of how much time Stuart Rhodes should do
um and then the prosecution will bring
their
preference of how many years Stewart
Rhodes should be sentenced to federal
prison
and then you'll have the judge's
decision
of what that sentencing will be
um it could be a dirty 30 where he gets
20 years and 10 years probation I I
actually probably believe between 15 and
18 years is what Stuart Rhodes is going
to receive for the charges that he's got
you know it's just me but maybe not it
could be a little less maybe it's the
whole 20 years I don't know but at
Stuart Rhodes is not going to see the
line today anytime soon
but I mean that's my guess 15 18 years
for trying to overthrow the government
wow
on the behest of Donald Trump
who incited the mob to the Capitol the
insurrectionist which there's dozens and
dozens and going to be hundreds of
convictions just just for the shart Army
that showed up
and was whipped into a frenzy to go
commit federal crimes
in the capital to try to overthrow our
government one of them getting shot and
killed
because of their [ __ ] chewing on
delusion
but imagine that
imagine in the history books
30 years 40 50 60 years from now
when the fabric of our democracy is
still strong
because you are paying attention
and you are engaging in your democracy
that's why it will be strong 50 60 years
from now
just imagine in the history books
when it says more than a thousand
people were imprisoned
because they acted on the behest of
Donald Trump
there's going to be a huge asterisk
next to anything this [ __ ] has
ever done and I don't care if it's
politically
I don't care if it's business wise I
don't even care if it's you know part of
culture
because really he lives inside of our
culture for some time
he's in rap songs he's been in movies
it's a stain a stain on our culture even
that this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] was able
to rise even to the level to be have his
name inserted into hip-hop songs
are into movies
he's a fraud he's a [ __ ] phony
he's a loser
and he's a [ __ ] Criminal
career baby
takes after his dad really
now his dad never got caught up on
criminal charges but baby
is this set of Trumps
and I I don't just mean Donald Trump I
mean some of these children too gonna
get caught up in the criminal system
17 counts of guilt
for the Trump organization
the business that he ran
that supposedly his children ran while
he was president
17 criminal counts
the good news is
now this is going to be a small fine
right
and maybe the Manhattan D.A actually
prosecutes individuals like the kids
other [ __ ] officers Donald Trump
himself
maybe you know I don't know I I actually
think that the fraud case is probably
better made in a federal court not the
Manhattan DA's office
but whatever
the civil case the Tish James has right
now where Trump organization is in
receivership
because of the civil case
there's a monitor that Court a court
appointed monitor because Donald Trump
it seemed as if he was trying to going
to move his money
and try to you know
skate accountability again
and now it's in receivership there's a
court appointed monitor
on Trump organization
and then yesterday 17 counts of crime if
if you're not aware the Civil Trial
when Tish James the Attorney General
gets this [ __ ] into the Civil
Trial stage of trump organization that
is a much lower bar
than what happened yesterday with the 17
counts of crime a criminal Jury has a
much higher bar to reach
to convict an individual or a business a
corporation an organization in the state
of New York
then they do a civil
trial this whole point between civil and
criminal criminals there's there's a
much higher bar
kiss James is going to cut the Trump
organization down like a fresh cut tree
and I'm here for it
folks he's not going anywhere
he's not going anywhere just just wait
in until we get into January
Trump is going to post something
supporting Kanye West
I'm not [ __ ] you this is gonna
happen
he's going to say something like Kanye's
rape
take it to the bank
bet on it I don't give a [ __ ] I'm
telling you right now he's gonna he's
gonna do that
that's how crazy this [ __ ] is
gonna get
he can't stand the oxygen being sucked
up in the room
that's why I ran for president really I
mean he could have waited until January
or February or whenever he was indicted
all he's trying to do is fend off a
[ __ ] criminal trial in 2024. that's
all he's trying to do
he knows he's going to be indicted he's
[ __ ]
I mean he's completely [ __ ] here
rather it's in Georgia rather it's in
D.C for the state elector scheme rather
it's for other acts in January 6th
rather it's the documents case
or if there's referrals out of the
Manhattan DA's office to the sdny
he's got a lot of criminal liability
here now I'm not really sure exactly
what all this looks like over the next
period of five years because I really do
believe that it's going to take about
five years from this point right now
to sort all the crime out not just with
him but with those thousands possibly of
people who are going to be convicted and
sent to [ __ ] prison
because they were convinced that he is
the Mussolini Jesus holy
[ __ ] I am so glad that you're here this
morning
Wednesday it's hump day happy happy hump
day
as you are here every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter and
twitch and simulcasting from Facebook
the Midas touch Facebook page if you're
over on Facebook
well follow us at the Tony Michaels if
you're on the Midas touch page also
don't forget to subscribe to YouTube
don't forget this because we put the
bonehead of the week pull up every
single week and tomorrow tomorrow we put
the poll up for bonehead of the week
we also put it up on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod you know what happens
tomorrow Thursday we'll put out the poll
Friday in the second hour we will go
through the bone of the week boy do we
have a lot of boneheads
already this week
holy moly and I got a lot of stuff I
want to show you in the [ __ ] list
Roundup
um
with some videos and oh oh oh oh
I almost forgot
it's so insignificant but I can't I
can't leave with the break and going to
the shitless Roundup before I mention
again the absolute obsession
of the the the right wing internet the
far right wing with Elon and Matt taibi
their [ __ ] Obsession because
yesterday
it's like Trump's guilty on 17 counts in
his business
in the state of New York guilty all
counts
and Elon Musk and Matt tave he's like
hey look at Hunter Biden's dick
hey hey over here hey oh hello oh look
we got dick pics
let's do some nitpicks
the [ __ ] the hunter Biden story is
getting more flaccid
by the moment holy actual [ __ ] well I'm
sure we'll talk about it today with Gabe
Sanchez I'm sure he'll have more to say
about the Twitter files supplement
thread
whoo that the genitalia obsessed right
posted yesterday after they found out
Donald Trump
and his organization
was guilty on 17 counts everyone stick
around don't go anywhere we'll be right
back right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
a video a clip uh officers
January 6th
of their family
[Music]
in his honor
and they absolutely threw shade on Mitch
McConnell and Kevin McCarthy and we
watched that clip yesterday now there is
another clip there's a more of an
extended explanation of why they did
what they did and I think it's very
relevant
very very relevant
and why
people like Herschel Walker lost people
like especially people like mastriano
in Pennsylvania
especially Carrie Lake Fenton
and Blake Masters lost
in Arizona
and the reason why
and and Tudor Dixon
in Michigan the reason why
is because of the the clip you're going
to see
the the absolute Ridiculousness that
somehow somehow some way
that the reason why
January 6 happened is because they
didn't do what they want they they
didn't get what they wanted
and they because they didn't get what
they wanted the American people deserved
to try to have their constitution
stomped on ripped up in shreds and their
government taken away from them their
democracy
at its at its total Foundation
overturned
and these these folks that lost their
loved one in that attack
because they were defending
their their constitution
and defending the oath they took
they explain it all too well of why
Kevin McCarthy and Mitch McConnell can
[ __ ] all the way off
I mean that's my way of saying it
of course
my way of saying they can you know
get a [ __ ] life
go to hell
get bent
kick rocks I mean there's a lot of ways
of saying it but [ __ ] all the way off
and just got a certain ring to it right
you can [ __ ] all the way the whole way
off
um so we got a lot of things but today
is December 7th and it's kind of it's
kind of you know I don't know it may be
fitting that it's December 7th you guys
know what December 7th is I'm sure the
freedom the freedom fighter Patriots
first Nazi party has no [ __ ] idea
what December 7th is or what it means
have no [ __ ] clue
FDR stood
days after
and talked about Pearl Harbor and the
attack on Pearl Harbor and the attack on
our democracy
fascist regimes
were Rising around the world
we were not in the war yet officially
even though
Britain wanted us in the war
and we were attacked
at Pearl Harbor on December 7 1941 a
date which will live an infant me
and really we should trudge up
what happened as a result of Pearl
Harbor and what are our people we the
people did
and how we stood up to defend not just
ourselves
but people around the world just as we
are helping defend Ukraine
from a murderous dictator Vladimir Putin
which the Republican Party loves that
[ __ ] seems kind of weird
but I'll tell you that even reflecting
on a day like today when you look at
history even all those years ago
no one would have ever ever guessed
in those moments
after Pearl Harbor after those words
from the president of the United States
who was a Democrat
FDR when he said
a date which will live an infamy
never dreamed
that we would have an Insurgency inside
the United States
to commit sedition
and treason because they're [ __ ]
snowflakes
and they can't handle losing
I just don't think in that moment
in our country at that time that we
would have ever dreamed that we would be
where we are right now and this is how
history works
as we look back we try to make sure
that we do not repeat history
and we are doing it as we speak we did
it Georgia did it last night and
yesterday and the days prior in the
early vote
we are not going to allow these fascists
to turn us into a fascist dictatorship
that is not something we are [ __ ]
willing to do
and until the Republican Party really
decides
that they want to be a party inside the
Democracy [ __ ] them
I I hope we throw that entire party into
the trash bin of history at this point
not one of them not even Mitt Romney we
showed a clip yesterday of Mitt Romney
at [ __ ] coward the Republican party
is the party of the Constitution no it
is not
no it is not you [ __ ] you did
this to yourselves you did this to our
country you set it up in a way where you
knew
you knew the road you were going down
you knew these [ __ ] chuckleheads that
you were putting in charge and you did
nothing you did nothing
well Romney voted to impeach him well
great future proofing vermit Romney that
was not hard hard
to see that the history books would pick
out the one Republican that voted to
impeach
so Mitt Romney's smart enough to know
that but his name will be written in the
history books that way but he will not
be written in the history books
as being courageous
courage courage would would Mitt Romney
When Donald Trump sent out a message
saying he wants to to terminate the
Constitution because it doesn't fit his
[ __ ] needs to be dictator should said
I am no longer a member of this party
that's what he should have said
you being a member of the [ __ ] party
makes you complicit in the treason in
the sedition
in the fascism you [ __ ]
and I don't know how long this will take
this process that we're undergoing in
our democracy because this is the
process that is happening
we have a minority ideological rule in
this country
what do I mean by that
setting party aside when you talk about
ideology right certain issues where you
stand
we have in this country in a lot of
states and in our federal government
specifically the Senate
where the minority of those ideas
of politics and policy
are in control
not the majority of ideas and policy
I'll give you an example
in my state
of Missouri everyone says oh it's a red
State a bunch of Republicans blah blah
blah yakety schmackity [ __ ] their
voting Republican but they're not
they're not you go talk to someone even
[ __ ] some of these Cuban honors and
you you talk about Bare Bones issues
like I don't know a decent wage
you just start talking to them about
making a decent wage
all of a sudden they start saying real
liberal Democratic type [ __ ]
they don't know it
and they don't care it's like Texas Paul
said yesterday you know they can't they
can't walk away from the LIE
that the Republican party is the party
they vote for
because of this because of that whatever
issue it is taxes abortion I'm gonna be
rich someday so I better vote for the
[ __ ] that are going to cut
taxes on rich people well why wouldn't
you vote for the [ __ ] party who cuts
taxes on the majority of people
brainwashed mind [ __ ] [ __ ]
and here's how they're brainwashing mind
[ __ ] it has nothing to do with
ideology it has nothing to do with
issues
it has to do with affiliation folks
that's what it is that's why they're so
desperate to hang on and to cling to
this this American Christianity that
they've created
and it's not working like it's not
working
because the newer Generations aren't
buying the [ __ ]
because they don't want to be Affiliated
okay there's a thing called third party
endorsement and when you when you are
part of an organization like a church or
a religion if you want to put it in a
broader stroke
or maybe even a class of people right
and locally because they say politics is
local but it's not the politics it's not
the policy that's really local it's the
affiliation and the third party
endorsement
we have an issue in this country
where people vote for a party be damned
their views on policy be damned
yeah there's a prime example here in
Missouri just like I was talking about
in Missouri
there was a referendum on the ballot in
the midterm
the referendum was for recreational
marijuana we had limited medical
marijuana in the state now there was
debate about the distributions and the
licensing you know on and on and on
but what happened was what has happened
when you put this kind of referendum on
any state ballot
it passes
people are in favor of not [ __ ]
criminally with people because of this
[ __ ] plant
pretty simple again you can get into the
weeds in the actual policy and the
licensing
of The Growers the sellers all that kind
of [ __ ] the taxation how that works
but here's the thing in Missouri
where
this third party endorsement
of marijuana because everyone's like
yeah well who gives a [ __ ] about weed
who gives a [ __ ] about marijuana anymore
it's a third party endorsement
that that majority of people starts to
push that issue but what's funny is the
same third party endorsement happens
to work against that referendum that
those same people voted for
these same [ __ ]
in my state who went and voted yes to
recreational marijuana decriminalize
this [ __ ] tax it let's make some [ __ ]
Revenue marijuana is not [ __ ] bad you
be bore out of your minds
they voted
to send Eric Schmidt who is one of the
he's the Attorney General right now the
state of Missouri he is he is one of the
most Vietnamese
enemies
of recreational marijuana
so they voted the majority voted in a
referendum at the state level to to
legalize the decriminalize really
recreational marijuana
but they voted to send a guy who is
absolutely the opposite of that
to the United States Senate where he
will vote accordingly
against their wishes of what they just
voted for
and this is all because of third-party
endorsement and affiliation
he only got that vote because he's got a
[ __ ] stupid R next to his name
and these mind [ __ ] boneheads
these Q Anon Elites because that's what
they are as Q Anon Elites folks we gotta
we gotta start making this right I don't
care what class or what what community
they're from they think they're Elite
because they know [ __ ] that we don't
know which is really [ __ ] weird and
[ __ ]
foreign they think the information that
they have that their delusion is based
off of is is is is very secret very in
tune information to only a certain group
of people they're the Q Anon Elites it's
[ __ ] weird I know but it that's just
the way it is
but this third party endorsement and
this affiliation is the reason why we
have these results of the minority of
ideas or ideology in this country
setting policy for us
they go to church they listen to Pastor
dumb [ __ ] tell them who they should vote
for because abortion murder
yeah abortion murder as if the broad
stroke of abortion is all murder
they know that's not [ __ ] true you go
to Kentucky you go to Kansas and you see
the results on a referendum
and they say [ __ ] you you're not taking
our rights away from us not all abortion
is what you say it is you dumb
[ __ ]
and at the same moment in the same
moment they vote for the person
who would absolutely take their rights
away from them
especially when it comes to the issue of
abortion now I know that sounds crazy
but the reason why it's so [ __ ] crazy
is because of affiliation and third
party endorsement
that's what it is folks that's what it
is
the America I I was very confident in
this election because of Roe and the
overturning of Roe because there's one
thing you do not tell Americans and we
learned anything from the pandemic it is
this you do not tell Americans what the
[ __ ] they can and what the [ __ ] they
cannot do that is one thing that
Americans as a whole right wrong
indifferent however you want to frame it
up in whatever issue it is placed into
that is something the American people
just do not stand for it's it's deep
down inside of our [ __ ] core it's
kind of ridiculous I mean not kinda it
really is kind of [ __ ] ridiculous but
that is that that is the foundation
of us as a collective is that you will
not we have freedom and you cannot tell
us what the [ __ ] do we do anything we
want whenever we want blah blah blah and
it's this white male privilege thing
that's the institution of of freedom in
this country but the point is this is
collectively that becomes our national
attitude
and that is affiliation folks it's
affiliation if you've ever been to a
party Gabe Sanchez have you ever been to
a party
and a bunch of people standing around
right um you know everybody's standing
around there's a subject comes up
doesn't have to be politics you know
it's maybe it's dick pics on the
internet
I'm sure I'm sure that's a big topic
among the GOP parties right well maybe
it's the issue of should we have dick
pics flying around on Twitter I don't
know maybe that's you but this group of
people it seems like the majority of
people in this group
are for the dick picks being flung all
over Twitter they just they just don't
care
that there's some guys huge hog just
spread around over and they don't care
if celebrities spread it either they
don't no they don't I mean as long as it
furthers their own narrative and their
own cause which is exactly this this
dick was a threat to our democracy
absolutely or at least a threat to their
uh their freedom of speech so let's say
let's say there's 10 people and nine out
of the 10 people vocally voice yeah
I don't care about the dick pics
whatever
I would almost bet a hundred percent of
the time the 10th person even if they
had a dissenting view nine out of ten no
[ __ ] way by affiliation and third
party endorsement is that person going
to publicly voice their opinion in that
moment now maybe maybe you might have
outliers but in general you're not going
to see this
um you see this in the Republican Party
more than anything because they're sheep
and they don't really you know use facts
and logic and rationale you know really
to to
step through this process of figuring
out what the [ __ ] is what what's truth
and what's not right but Frank Luntz you
know Frank luntzes
uh
uh why does that name something familiar
let me see yeah look up Frank Luntz look
him up you'll know exactly who he is as
soon as you as soon as you he he has
done more more [ __ ] more [ __ ] good
well bad in reality for our democracy
but the journalists yeah well easy on
the journalist all right all right I
mean he's a communications consultant
that's right so what he does is he does
a lot of these these uh polls in real
time right he's on Fox News a lot and
they do you know these what how do you
feel how do you feel you know why does
it take qualitative polls where he goes
to ask people questions and they say
they're in a group he hasn't raised
their hand right okay I did see one it
wasn't him but I did see one they did in
Georgia in some like rural area of
Georgia yesterday and they're like who's
voting for Warnock and it was vote who's
voting for Warnock and one guy raise the
hand one and they're like one okay great
who's voting for uh Walker and like and
they're like well I guess that settles
it and it's like that's not how polling
really works but and that that is that
is third party endorsement and that's
affiliation right because what happens
is if you are affiliated with the group
just like yay we're delusional then
other people who are affiliated it
doesn't have to be affiliation of like
church now we have that problem but it
can be it can be economic status it can
be Community it can be race it can be
gender I mean there's all sorts of
there's all sorts of affiliation right
all sorts of affiliation you know rather
we want to admit it or not it's there
and that third party endorsement from
your Affiliated Group whatever it is
pushes your decision and that's what we
have that's why we have a situation in
our country where people are voting
for politicians that are doing the
opposite of what their actual [ __ ]
views are and it's because of their
affiliation and and the Republicans have
done this so well and I'm saying we need
to do this and we're doing it really
well with Gen Z that's why I'm so
excited about jinsi jinsi understands
affiliation gen Z understands third
party endorsement they understand this
they totally understand this in real
time the other thing they understand
more than anything is communication the
internet and social media
um bad better worse whatever yeah they
really understand it and because it's
been their entire life right there
there's been no other reality right like
people who uh grew up before there was
television and then there was television
like what the [ __ ] is this I mean there
was a television generation right right
I mean there is Gen Z grew up on Wi-Fi
was always connected and everything was
pinch and zoom touch kind of mannerisms
like every
that's and that's the truth and that
people just like I asked my
eight-year-old daughter we were at the
table and we were um someone brought up
CDs oh yeah compact discs okay compact
disc and um not certificates of deposit
because if you if you get in front of a
really right right someone who has some
age on them like CD certificate up to
Bob's yeah we had those down at the bank
but when you say CD like compact disc my
daughter's like
um we're like do you even know what a CD
is she's like and then she finally you
know we had to describe it oh yeah
that's yeah but yeah who has a [ __ ]
CD anymore yeah yeah no one has a CD
anymore right the point is the point is
is that different Generations live in
different Generations that's that's the
idea so there was a generation that had
no TV and then all of a sudden this TV
thing comes into the [ __ ] social fear
sphere and and it's right out there in
the public and it's it's it's got
information and it's flashy and it makes
your eyes you know pay attention and
there's no ways that comes out of this
[ __ ] you know this magic box and
there's a picture and eventually there
was color right there was a generation
after that that didn't have anything but
that that knew like like we're the video
game generation right right we didn't
there wasn't not video games yeah yeah
my parents are the TV generation I I
almost bet
I my son
who who is in high school I almost bet I
couldn't even get him to figure out how
to work an actual television not a
monitor a actual television like with
knobs and dials right well I mean even
even just he he looks at the remote like
you just introduced him to running water
I mean like what the [ __ ] where's the
touch screen on this thing you know what
I mean I mean I remember I had TV at our
one of the original TVs that we had at
the house when I was a kid was like the
hard like it was set to like the 20 some
odd channels it's like
right not to date myself here yeah
rotary phone you know I've got one I've
got one but here's here's what I'll tell
you just like
just like you were talking about the
knobs and getting used to you're so used
to the knobs and you don't want to go to
anything else it's the same thing with
our with political affiliation that is
why it's so important for us as
pro-democracy people to absolutely wedge
and tear down the Republican party to
its Bare Bones if necessary
and it's not because we want Republicans
to be a certain way it's because to
operate in a democracy in our democracy
we really to be long-term and to have
our fabric be strong we really need two
parties we really do that's the system
that's how it works
but we what we have to have two parties
that are interested yeah in democracy
and we do not have that right now that
is our trouble
as we have one party that is interested
in democracy the other party is
interested in destroying it like
fundamentally want to rip it away the
leader of their party that a former
president of their party is saying [ __ ]
Constitution [ __ ] that thing terminating
also said I never said I never said I
terminated I want to determinate is what
I said yeah it's weird it's weird and
then he gets he gets 17 uh counts for
his organization oh boy listen we
yesterday it was a great day I've been
saying this we live in one of the
wildest times
it is it is
I mean Drake was right what a time to be
alive what a time to be alive it is a q
Anon World we're just living in it hey I
got some clips I want to show you
speaking of um yeah speaking of
politicians we showed a clip of Mitch
McConnell and Kevin McCarthy having
shade thrown on them but I not I got
another clip of that same family who
told them to [ __ ] off basically with
their actions
um they explain it a little more and I
want to do that in the shitless Roundup
so let's do this let's start the
countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and for all of you out there listening
to the butt what the [ __ ] yeah listening
to the podcast now you should come over
and watch it on YouTube don't forget to
subscribe to the YouTube we got smooth
transitions yeah we got Smith smooth
transitions see that boom boom it's so
soft
smooth soft and silky
um anyways I want to get people riled up
out there I want to show you this clip
this clip is amazing
um the family explains why they why they
did not give a fine [ __ ] if Mitch
McConnell and Kevin McCarthy were there
as Leaders of their party to show
respect to their relative who was killed
this is Officer Brian sitnik and during
the January 6 attack which the Cheeto
dust q and honor and cited on the
capitol here is their family uh should
we actually you know what we should
probably show the um
the clip of what happened first yeah set
it up before and after give us some
context I mean we showed it yesterday
but you know there was a there was a
follow-up clip of Mitch McConnell oh
yeah day or yesterday I forget you can
find this see if you can find that well
I'm playing that this is this is what
was going around yesterday where they
basically told uh McConnell and McCarthy
to [ __ ] off which I think is the
appropriate that's the appropriate
response to anything Mitch McConnell
like you know Mitch McConnell comes and
orders a sandwich at Subway [ __ ] off you
know like whatever it is it doesn't
matter what it is but let's watch this
he's got his hand out
please shake my hand please please no
and Nancy Pelosi oh my God
and she's like ah and of course at the
end of this clip that I have here
doesn't have but everyone claps really
loud because they're receiving an award
as you can see well here you can see
Kevin McCarthy and Mitch McConnell are
holding some of the gold medal Awards
right and the entire audience the entire
room claps
but it appears
um in some ways in this clip that
they're clamping that these people
basically told them to [ __ ] off
um but here is their reasoning behind it
I think it was um our good friend yes I
think it was Scott McFarlane
um actually got this answer from the
family there let's listen
[Music]
self-explanatory but you know they they
came out right away and condemned what
happened on January 6th and whatever
hold
that Trump has on them they've backed up
the advanced they won't admit to
wrongdoing not necessarily them
themselves but of the Riders I mean
people like people like Louis Bowman
who presented the American flag that was
flown over the capitol through January
6th wide
and told them they were a patriot it's
disgusting now it takes away everything
my brother's done
I think that
that piece of content that Louis Gomer
because he posted this on social media
it's not like he just did this and there
was a report of it right [ __ ]
took video of this thing and what he's
talking about and I forget the name and
the lady who uh actually got locked up
because of her her involvement in the
riot and the Insurrection but as she was
being
um released is where he gave her this
flag in honor of her patriotism which is
gross like the like the relative of
Officer Sydney says here just vile and
disgusting
um
but it is that moment that they are
producing the they are producing and
making sure the public sees this this
vile garbage that Louis Gomer did again
it's not like he went to a private
ceremony or something and gave this flag
and it just so happened the reporters
found out about it and reported on it
they were proud to post this video on
his social media right and it is it's
something else to see
um officer sick and his family to take
that piece of information to show that
it's not only the act of January 6.
it's their continued support of a coup
and it's their continued support of a
violent Insurrection that killed their
[ __ ] relative
like who was protecting the Constitution
not trying to terminate it or overthrow
it or hang the vice president they were
trying to protect the Constitution
what's this link here you sent me what
so this is uh this is McConnell
he had a
he was answering some questions
yesterday and this is
him getting asked about that moment
oh so this is a a gaggle looks like and
the reporters are he's had a microphone
here and reporters are gonna
um question him about how he's he stood
there with his hand out and knowing no
one would change yeah they're so mean
that people are mean people are mean
let's listen
to president Trump's actions after
January 6th yeah I would respond by
saying today we gave the gold medal to
the heroes of January 6th we admire and
respect them they laid their lives on
the line and that's why we gave a gold
medal today to the heroes of January 6.
um so I want to go back here that that I
walked away like a coward
narrative to be that he's in he's in
support of of blue lives matter and
police officers and protecting the
Constitution all at the same time he
wants to support Donald Trump and a
complete non-answer how do you respond
to the families that did not shake your
hand when you were giving the medals
well today we gave them medals to the
heroes if that really was how you felt
if that really is how you feel
and maybe it is who knows but
we also know that you're a [ __ ]
coward right
to the Senate vote by saying no no I
won't impeach Donald Trump for in sign
into violence and causing the death of
these people that I believe are heroes
but then after the vote's done then in
your speech say well look you know what
we need to realize here guys is that it
is Donald Trump's fault he is
responsible like even though I just
voted that he wasn't yeah well you know
I want to point out here because I don't
know if you know who this guy is in the
background you know who this guy is no
Senator this is Senator Roy blunt of
Missouri he's the one that retired and
um the Eric Schmidt our our scumbag
attorney general won that seat
um now Roy blunt here looks like he
cannot [ __ ] wait because he's part of
leadership
and and Roy bond is significant in
January 6. and the reason why is because
after January 6 Roy blunt was the one
who was responsible for the ceremony of
transfer of power I don't know if anyone
knows that but Roy blunt organized
the the inauguration for Joe Biden okay
that's what happened
now
Roy blunt here looks like on his face
he's like I cannot wait to retire from
the party of treason right yeah like
holy [ __ ] what a cluster [ __ ] like
literally we can't even we can't even
give medals away anymore without taking
questions from reporters afterwards of
why the family thinks we're treasonous
pieces of garbage yeah like what the
[ __ ] I mean it kind of reminds me of
when
like let's say a company does something
right they they commit some uh tax fraud
I don't know well yeah who knows
something more something on like
Community like let's say there were a
water company and they I didn't have
pure water or they weren't cleaning the
water and it caused I knew about it or
something and they knew about it and
then this is their moment of like okay
well we'll pay the fines
but we won't acknowledge that we were at
fault like we'll pay we'll we'll give
the money because the court said we
would but we're not going to apologize
and own up that yes we were at fault and
it was our problem this is just this is
the uh
the verdict that was given we don't
agree to it but we'll pay the money
because we are legally bound to do so
now and that's the way that I look at
this is they're giving away the medals
to these Heroes actual Heroes that
fought and and and gave their life to
protect this capital
and then at the same time these people
are like well we we gave them medals we
gave them medals guys we gave them hero
medals and it's like Well if you really
believe that then you would apologize
for not saying something earlier for not
defending their name and their honor if
you [ __ ] back the blue so much or the
fact that you would own up and be like
yeah Donald Trump was the problem and
I'm going to vote to impeach him
but you didn't do that so when I see
this it very much tells me of someone
who's trying to like pay off or like
bribe a family or something like that to
be like right good you're good you you
got it it's what you said the other day
it's future proofing right right exactly
it's future proofing the reason why
Mitch McConnell shows up at the ceremony
rather he believes it or not or he's
he's all in on giving a medal for
officer sicknick dying on the day of the
Insurrection because Donald Trump
incited a riot in a violent Insurrection
to overthrow our Constitution and our
government and our democracy whether he
believes it or not he's future proofing
right he's standing there he's in
support because he wants to make sure
people knows that what what they have to
knows and then when he gets in front of
the microphone he gets asked he's future
proofing well dude lately they're the
heroes and then all in the same breath
when asked if Donald Trump is a nominee
will you support him we'll also support
whoever the Republican nominee is right
like okay so you're so it's two
different things then yeah it's two
different things you have no very it's
very hard for the Republican party to
own up and give a yes no answer and
respond to be like yes I will vote for
him if he is or no I won't it's just
well look it's a
it's a ways away why are we even talking
about this it's exactly what you said
it's future proofing but it's future
proofing for their power yeah right like
Liz Cheney and Adam kinsinger they were
not willing to Future proof for their
power right they decided to take a more
honorable stance and say look I'm not
going to stand around and [ __ ]
placate to your [ __ ] and your life
nature proof my power right exactly and
whether you've got kids in here who's
like I'm not gonna pursue another term
you know obviously looking at that
whether he goes into the private side or
he says I'm gonna go for office some
some on something else right in the
state of Illinois uh or I don't know or
something much grander and then you got
Liz Cheney obviously who who lost to uh
[ __ ] crazy uh oh my God what the [ __ ]
is her name the Kerry Lane all right
wish.com Carrie Lake holy Zach that's
gonna be fun that's gonna be fun over
the next two years yeah it's gonna be
exciting we're gonna have plenty of
clips of that crazy [ __ ] weird
um she and Liz Cheney in in kenzinger
are I look at them and I say obviously
different different circumstance as to
how they ended their career for right
now
but certainly end it on a high note
right especially as someone who's like
I'm a conservative or I'm a republican
they say look I defended the
Constitution I believed in democracy or
I still believe in democracy but I
defended where we stand as a country to
not let this treasonous act go on I
worked to make sure that this is the
party that we still have despite these
crazies going into office and spreading
these crazy conspiracy theories this and
then
so they put they've definitely put
themselves in a position they looked at
it whether they they resigned or they
were voted out right well but but it's
not it is a it is a sign that they're
not willing to Future prove just for
their own power right right now I
believe Liz Cheney is a little I would
say also a little late obviously because
you know their their voting record was
very much tow well and it took it I mean
it took a long time right a long time
for Liz Cheney who was third in in the
uh ladder of power in her party in the
house when it happened the January 6
Insurrection but it took a long time
after the 2020 election for Liz Cheney
to go to the floor and say it's over
it's like 190 days is how long it took
her to get to the floor of the house and
and get on the record so you know she's
no saint either and really you know I
think Liz Cheney's playing the long game
for power she's not future proofing in
the moment for her power she's she's
playing a long game
um but there is is people who have
courage still in this world and I am
actually excited that the person of the
year is handed to someone who did some
good A lot of times they there was a
moment there was a brief moment when I
saw like the list of contenders yeah
oh my God I think Rhonda Santos was in
there yeah
go [ __ ] himself at this point but
um zielinski president zielinski of
Ukraine uh gets and I think this was
announced just hours ago
um and they they were releasing
yesterday or the day before the the the
nominees
um for this award but we all know that
sometimes this doesn't really mean much
um when when Hitler was the person of
the year at some point in times history
it really does kind of
um like that's still like I don't know
should they go back and just revoke that
be like look we I mean I don't uh what
was the re did they say what the
reasoning was well I mean they don't
they don't they don't always select the
person of the year because it's like a
good thing it's just like the most
impactful yeah in some ways it's kind of
like a popularity contest right right
right instead of just good it doesn't
have to be good popularity like it could
be like famous or like infant and this
kind of thing right but um uh president
zielinski
um surprised the entire world really I
think and that's why he's the person of
the year is because he has surprised the
entire world yeah I I and maybe he even
has surprised himself I don't know
um this is a guy who's an actor a
comedian who never dream you know in in
our country that some actor or comedian
would be
um so so courageous I mean a lot of
people put the guy you know a Target on
him and said this guy's going to be gone
within a few weeks there's no way
survive this if he doesn't leave an
exile kind of but but it certainly it
certainly is something to show you like
you know these these you can't
you know I guess when you look back at
these these people who have been chosen
for Time Magazine right and you're like
oh you know what did they do or whatever
you know and you obviously want to hope
that there's some symbol of Hope
um
but you also have to realize that's a
situation like this like he didn't
[ __ ] choose this he wasn't like I
mean he you know like there I I can't
tell you a moment in which he probably
would have been considered for something
or gotten to the level
of kind of worldwide
um household name status if it wasn't
for this but again it really goes back
like this don't choose those moments
they they're the moments choose them it
chooses them and it's how how they could
have ran he could have ran and really
honestly he could have capitulated to
Trump
um when when Trump pressured him which
was the first impeachment uh when Trump
pressured him to announce that there was
investigations in the Joe Biden and
Hunter Biden's dick right um
I mean literally that's what we've been
talking about and I'm sure we'll get to
the Twitter files supplemental dick pic
uh Saga for maybe five minutes today
because that's about all that it's worth
yeah but I've got some [ __ ] to say about
that but right but but the the fact is
is that uh zielinski came to uh
worldwide prominence especially in this
country with the first impeachment trial
of Donald Trump because he didn't bear
under the pressure if you remember the
actual trial in the Senate
um zlenski was not one that beared under
the pressure of Donald Trump and his
team to try to get him to do this thing
um it seemed as if he was but zielinski
was really being uh you know put into a
rough spot where they needed Aid to
defend themselves against Russia but
also really wanted to make sure that
they they could secure a meeting with
United States officials
um to secure that Aid which they are now
because Joe Biden likes democracy and I
mean all you know I I also think about
this possible scenario let's say that
Trump did win in 2020 you would not find
this scenario playing out the way it did
you know especially when you say like
okay great you know they were able to
defend themselves early on with just
what they had
but in order to fight against a genocide
by a dictator as Putin
you look at it and you say
Trump would have completely caved and
been like I can't do anything like I
could send some stuff but like
he's got those peepee tapes on me you
know like I can't do anything oh I think
boot I think Putin's got way worse the
Trump does not let me exposure obviously
he's he tapes as we know Putin is uh
clearly [ __ ] in the bed over there
literally I mean well uh fell down the
stairs and [ __ ] his pants or something
what is he what's that story here you
have here you have the president of
Ukraine defending defending a flimsy
democracy because I'll even admit this
Ukraine is no perfect democracy yeah it
is no it is no Beacon of what a
democracy should be it has had a lot of
corruption inside his democracy it's
taken decades and decades to even get to
the point where they would elect someone
like zielinski to be the president to
try because his campaign to become
president was basically anti-corruption
was his campaign and now he's just the
[ __ ] General I mean it's crazy how
like you said moments choose you
um but here's a guy who ran on
anti-corruption to try to fix the
democracy and unbeknownst to him that
national pride and the the actual want
and desire for democracy actually was
the thing that defended it more than any
anti-corruption policy good because
really that's the story of Ukraine and
the story of zelinski here I think is
that
um the Ukrainian people really truly
believe
fundamentally at their Foundation that
it is more important for their Nation to
survive
than anything other
than than it's non-survival at this
point and democracy is the Keynote
in that survival like that is the thing
that that Rings true with solensky um
regardless of him being
um rather he's going to get a NATO or
not and yeah you know there's a lot of
uh policy stuff and and the world policy
towards him but they again we've been
giving him Aid because we are democracy
we believe in democracy here
um at least the majority of us do right
so I I want to congratulate time on
selecting a decent [ __ ] nominee here
um someone who deserves it as opposed to
just the popularity contest exactly I
mean 100 in
this is hands down there's there should
be no doubt as to who should be the
recipient of this year's time you know
person of the year and also to the to
the question of uh what's the story on
the poo poo Putin oh yeah yeah yeah uh
basically what's the [ __ ] yourself story
yeah yeah he fell on his tailbone he was
walking down the stairs and he fell on
his tailbone oh so this is like your
heels slip out from underneath you
because that's more than likely how
you'd kind of fall down on your ass
right yeah yeah you think it's falling
falling like if you trip forward you
wouldn't fall on your [ __ ] tailbone
right right so this is like you know you
slide down the [ __ ] stick yeah you
miss a step or your heel or something
yeah yeah so he he landed on his his
coccyx which is the is the tailbone whoa
whoa is this more Hunter Biden talk Cox
you never know I mean the pp tapes and
okay but uh it is
um he fell on his tailbone not saying
that caused him to [ __ ] himself but uh
he did [ __ ] himself involuntarily so it
wasn't like he found was like ah I'm
gonna poop right here it was oop I poop
and I [ __ ] myself uh and so do we have
video evidence of this because I would
really like to show I don't think I'm
sure it was ever video evidence you know
me I love I love the video evidence
if there was video evidence Putin was
like
you are dead right now killed killed the
cameraman oh the cameraman is dead
um I guarantee that's uh that's what
happened holy [ __ ] so yeah Putin [ __ ]
himself
after he slipped on the steps I I I'll
say man I never broke my tailbone but
I've talked to people and they're like
it is the most excruciating because they
can't do anything like yeah yeah put
your ass in a cast or anything right
like yeah right they I mean sometimes
you have to have surgery on it because
it's so [ __ ] painful they got to like
remove part of it and [ __ ] I I do know
one person in high school who had that
happen to them and they had like a
little like saw they well first off they
just like didn't come to school for a
while and then when they did they gotta
lay down you can't yeah yeah well then
when they did when they even Did
Standing they had a a butt pillow they
had a little donut pillow yeah yeah uh
to kind of alleviate any pressure but it
was it was I mean so he walked around
with a backpack and a button I don't
even know if they I think they had
someone carry their because you can if
you have a certain injury like let's say
that you you know broke up a body right
you can't like crutches you have someone
who right who can carry those books so a
volunteer student yeah like about yeah
pretty much and so they just like bring
the books to the class or whatever but
yeah uh that's that's what I remember
from high school and I'm like oh god
I've known a couple people who have uh
broke their tailbone and it is it I I've
never done it but it is they say it's
one of the most excruciating things
they've ever been through because it
affects you for a really long time
because you don't really know how much
you sit down until you break your ass so
right so you know Putin sitting much
it's probably because he got the tip of
his tail knocked off so you know but did
the [ __ ] yourself thing I've never heard
that I've never heard like I've never
like I've had a few people tell me that
they fell and you know broke their tail
but I don't know maybe he was holding a
[ __ ]
what happened yeah was Putin was like oh
no oh no you know when like you got it
ready it's like oh God it's like prairie
dog oh yeah yeah you got a whole you
gotta put your hand on the end you know
like it's like you're driving home and
your body knows like you're like your
mind and your body your stomach is
please please no just like give me a
second and you're like running to the
door you know I think that's kind of
what happened uh as yeah karushi says
crowning uh I'm crowning you got the you
got you know you got the turtle head
poking out that's right you got the
prairie dog poking right it's like in
that movie you're going to explode like
in uh Dumb and Dumber is that the one
where he gives him the laxatives yeah
yeah
if you remember in the movie uh if you
ever saw the movie Rat Race the little
girl they're like every there's a big
competition out there to find this money
but there's a little girl in the back
seat and this family and they're part of
this competition and she's like I can't
I can't hold it in anymore and they're
like well can you and she's like I'm
prairie dog and they're like what does
that mean and it's like it means and
they're like oh my God that's so gross I
think that's what happened here he was
like rushing down to the bunkers he was
getting back down to his bunker slipped
on the heel boom hit it and just [ __ ]
and just and you're like oh and then he
was like well while I'm here I might as
well finish the job because I mean
really if you think about it like if
you're really clinching them butt cheeks
together right like I mean you're
holding it on for dear life right and
you you've got him yeah you're power
walking you're waddling and you're
holding your hand on your ass I mean
because if you're holding one hand on
your ass and the other hand on your
stomach you don't have much balance
probably walking down to say you're off
yeah and you miss one of them [ __ ]
stairs like the edge of it because
you're going too bad
and and as soon as you slip you're
probably gonna let those muscles go yeah
right because you're going to try to
catch yourself it's you know
it's right probably how that moment is
like you lose all control so any any
sense of like oh I got this then you let
it it's gone it's gone like on the way
maybe he did it like he was like and
then he like hit the tailbone and the
[ __ ] was there maybe I broke well maybe
it did so I mean depending on how I mean
really you know it's if it's like soupy
poopy probably not but if it's like you
know if it had something to it some some
Mass to it it might have softened up he
may not have broke his tailbone that bad
yeah you know because he he had a he had
a shitty kind of fall it's just like
that is just something that you can't
recover from or once people know that
you [ __ ] your pants in public that's
like somebody at a dinner on the party
right I I it's like someone at a dinner
party gotta follow you around forever oh
yeah no no any any people that's like if
you're in kindergarten you [ __ ] your
pants you go to like your 30th High
School reunion you're like weren't you
the gay you [ __ ] your pants again no and
you're like yeah dude you're sure yeah
you shoot your kids man and you know you
should own up into it when you're like
in kindergarten right like you [ __ ]
ain't right I [ __ ] my pants you should
have seen that [ __ ] but like
when you're Putin now the other the
other scenario is that his health is
horrible anything and he's in con and
he's incontinent yeah yeah and and I
mean just like Trump right and you know
maybe he had diapers to catch it at the
pens but um he might have had diapers to
catch the [ __ ] who knows and I don't
know if the [ __ ] and the falling was
all in one incident or if I'd like to
think it was all just one that's what
really that the image of him having to
hold oh my God all right yeah I gotta
[ __ ] in my pants right and I am running
to the code
you know like he's getting down to the
bunker and he's like got to drop off
this this missile oh good you know like
that's what I I that's what we want to
believe and and here's the thing because
we don't have a report if it's straight
enough it's true it's true right
so um fake Gabe copy that [ __ ] and put
it in some chants somewhere yeah you're
the you're the king of uh copy and
pasting so will you do this that favor
um
speaking of speaking of [ __ ] everywhere
and a total actual garbage [ __ ] uh Matt
taibi I know you want to talk about this
boy I know you want a dog and there's a
tiny thread he's trending uh is there a
new one or is it the one yesterday his
supplemental yeah the supplemental
that's the one I'm figuring this [ __ ] is
so [ __ ] dumb all right so here's the
tldr wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait
I mean you're saying this is so [ __ ]
dumb but this is supposed to be like the
evidence that's supposed to back up the
evidence that was supposed to destroy
that is destroying the entirety this was
literally supposed to bring down the
Biden campaign the Biden presidency
everything's gonna be null and void once
everyone realizes that Hunter Biden's
dick was on every Republican's mind
they couldn't stop obsessing about his
huge [ __ ] and that's the really that's
the story is Hunter Biden's got a huge
dick yeah like he's got a huge [ __ ] they
are very you know it's projection
insecurity right uh it's their
do you think that's what they hate about
it the most like God why does he why
does this this liberal president's son
have such a huge [ __ ] is that like
Donald Trump I think Junior does the
[ __ ] things is because he's trying to
tell us I wish it was this I wish it was
this big I mean like you know she said
it was this big right
um I think I think the way that I look
at it is not only they're like oh man
I'll never have that big of a dong but
they also look at her like oh man I'll
Never Be Loved by my parents or my
father like that regardless of how much
I [ __ ] up and I'm not a good person the
things that I do or whatever it might be
I think a lot of them look at that and
they're like oh my God that's what
empathy looks like I want that for
Christmas or my dad to love me or it
could be that for Christmas they want
they are really pissed off that their
shalong isn't big enough to be posted on
Twitter maybe maybe destroy democracy
destroy them I mean maybe Santa will
send them uh a photo like you know how
people have like vision boards right
maybe he'll give them a vision board
which is like Hunter Biden's dick
plaster on there and maybe they won't
even need it because what's that a
flashed picture of his dick or was this
like an erection uh
several there's several photos of him so
maybe some of them are hard some of them
are soft I mean and I don't know is he a
grower or is he a shower I don't know I
have no idea the other thing too is like
I don't know how many other photos they
have that they weren't allowed to spread
online but they're privately at their
home being like Oh yes Zoom enhanced
Zoom enhance oh my God how many more
words can we use to describe Hunter
Biden's sausage for the Republicans I
don't know uh uh
use his wenis his penis that anaconda
and uh we could say oh man that pipe I
mean they're obsessed with it so you
think they got like a list you guys got
a list out there that like how to
describe the um the Democracy killing
[ __ ] that is Hunter Biden's weiner is
there is there like a list out there
that you guys copy and paste Lincoln Log
Cebu says uh Hunter's Lincoln Log that
was pretty good that one's pretty good
I'm gonna I'm gonna put it out there if
you guys uh have other ones feel free
yeah feel free to send them in the chat
I will say um
the other thing that's funny about this
is
uh
uh oh man I totally blanked on it what
was I gonna well that's because you got
cocked on your mind I know this is what
happens the Republicans think too much
about dick on their mind another man's
penis like Hunter Biden I think it is
gonna own PR uh President Obama and they
don't have any sort of policy wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait President Obama I'm sorry president
by oh yeah see see who knows they're
probably think about his too they could
be they could be that's maybe what
they're really pissed off about is they
don't have pictures of his
um so tell me about I did I you know
what to be quite honest
this is the only thing I've read is
threat Matt TYB posted thread Twitter
final supplemental and I knew it was all
[ __ ] it follows if it follows the
similar format as before there's a lot
of exposition a lot of [ __ ] in the
beginning
here's where things uh so scroll up to
the one above my jaw Hit the Floor okay
right here over the weekend over the
weekend yeah so is talking about this
other report or this other woman Barry
Wise right and she says over the he says
over the weekend while we both dealt
with obstacles to new searches because I
guess that they were so this wise um um
reporter is helping him with this now is
that yeah they're now the two people
that are like they've been given right
this stuff under
certain conditions remember that under
certain conditions and they've also said
previously that there was no government
involvement and again remember that in
the 2020
October 2020 Biden was not elected and
he was not president so just keep those
things in mind because hang on hang on
we got a few uh there's the uh big
baloney Regina has a big baloney that's
a pretty good one
um
Irish Snake Charmer oh yeah okay okay
all right dongzilla
oh yeah
I can just imagine just like
that could be like a [ __ ] movie
Hunter
Zilla Mr Mr happy I'm sure I'm sure it
could be and and of course it's all on
um
anyways back to the back to the the
substance of what Matt taibi was right
right not finding out so so basically
they were like oh uh we we were supposed
to come out with a part two the
following day and then we were delayed
again and it never happened and then
they did the Q a which wasn't really a q
a yeah yeah
so well actually they didn't do a q a
the first day they're like we'll do a q
a for part two but then they never had a
part two and then that was pretty much
yeah right it's all [ __ ] so in this
one he's now working I guess he's has
been or now working with Barry Wise and
she says over the or he says over the
weekend while we bolt out with obstacles
new searches it was Barry Weiss who
discovered that the person in charge of
releasing the files was someone named
Jim when she called to ask Jim's last
name the answer came back Jim Baker
again a lot of drama a lot of [ __ ]
over drama time
this has been over sensationalized
instead of being like Oh look The person
who was in charge of giving us the files
was Jim Baker Jim Baker has a history of
doing XYZ this is literally over the
five dick pic post right right right so
then you go to the next suite and it
goes my jaw Hit the Floor says wise like
I'm reading a [ __ ] novel right now
the first batch of files both reporters
received marked Spectra Baker emails and
it's a screenshot and then you go to the
next tweet yeah
and then it says uh Baker's already
really boring I like the cocktalk more
why don't they go back to chilling okay
so then it goes Baker is this is where
it gets interesting Baker is a
controversial figure he has been
something of a zelig of FBI
controversies dating back to 2016 from
the steel dossier to the uh Alpha server
mess he resigned in 2018 after
investigation into leaks into the press
the news that Baker was received or was
reviewing the Twitter files why why is
that what the hell is it the files that
have to do with Hunter Biden or what no
yeah the Twitter files it's all the
Twitter files they're just they're
umbrella they're they're put under
umbrella of every file email document
report whatever under this whole
situation of Hunter Biden's but why are
they called Twitter files that would
mean that that would because I think
they're playing on this whole like
X-Files [ __ ] like it's supposed to be
some controversy are they just are they
trying to are they trying to message
here the that Twitter is the one at
fault for this yes they're trying to say
Twitter which is which is totally
[ __ ] stupid because Twitter's not the
government Twitter's a [ __ ] private
entity they have a terms of service and
the fact of the service what the [ __ ] is
it they're trying to make the argument
that it was Twitter and the government
but again
and he wasn't present it was still well
and is that the is that the argument
that they're trying to make here with
with Baker is that what they're trying
to do yeah so then they're looking in
this thing like all right the news the
baker reviewing the Twitter file
surprised everyone involved to say the
least new Twitter Chief Elon Musk acted
quickly to exit Baker Tuesday now here's
where this [ __ ] story yeah just Falls
flat in its face all right okay Elon
Musk he's a genius right no everyone
says yeah I know but everyone says
he doesn't invent anything he's never
invented he's a dumb takes credits buys
it does whatever anyway Elon Musk genius
right right
what you see here is a man who paid 44
billion because it started as a joke and
he got coordinated into doing it because
conservatives said free speech First
Amendment protect our rights right so he
said I'm gonna buy for 44 billion when
it's not even worth probably 10 billion
so just keep in mind for the size of the
loan that he got from a bank he could
have paid
for the actual value of the company and
some he took 13 billion
the company's really worth probably 10
or so billion well and that's why that's
why I kind of uh uh overestimated elon's
intelligence because I really thought
he'd do the smart thing and just do the
buyout and leave Twitter alone but you
know right exactly so what happens is he
pays 44 billion for a company
mm-hmm he gets a [ __ ] fire hose of
tweets data because they have to review
the whole bot claim or whatever
oh my God I real I true Moose's knuckle
oh my God that the [ __ ] I I gotta tell
everyone
um if you're listening to this and
you're not going to the [ __ ] chats
either on Facebook or YouTube of people
posting
um
Insurrection at his Capital
um of people posting um names for Hunter
Biden's dick you're missing out you're
true sorry I didn't mean to interrupt I
just I can't you know like you know we
need a little break for dick right yeah
so what happens is he he pays 44 billion
for a company he has all of the due
diligence that he can get he meets with
the legal counsel he talks to Jack he
deals with the CEO at the time he deals
with the legal counsel at Twitter right
he meets everyone he meets everyone Tony
he knows exactly who everyone is
he knows every [ __ ] person his
lawyers meets with their lawyers he
meets with their lawyers all that
[ __ ] yeah so
so Elon then says if I can I'll find the
Tweet but Elon basically says I only
just found out about this guy's
involvement on Sunday wait wait wait
wait wait Sunday Sunday meaning two days
like the last Sunday or the Sunday
before last like this came like this was
released yesterday on Tuesday he's
saying that two days prior Monday Sunday
wasn't the original Twitter file or
whatever the [ __ ] done before then it
was no but what they're saying the
reason their reason oh my God that he's
fired what happened all that fact
checking he was doing in the 40 minutes
leading up to the original drop well the
reason what they said was happening was
they said oh well there was a lot of
collusion from uh from baker's part
Baker was supposedly now for anyone who
doesn't know this
Baker is the legal counsel to Twitter
okay legal counsel
he's there to do due diligence when
things go out on behalf of the company
right so when a bunch of files so he's
like quality control type thing yeah he
pretty much so when a bunch of files go
out
and are are shared right he has to be
the one that reviews them to make sure
oh this isn't revealing company Secrets
or whatever I have to make sure that
we're not just haphazardly sending
something out that exposes something
um again company Secrets people's names
whatever it might be
then
uh Matt haibi goes oh my God we realized
that this guy was Baker Baker worked for
the FBI FBI sealed dossier Trump this is
[ __ ] uh uh suppression okay so if you
scroll up to the the above tweet you see
a lot of tweets that are doing this
that that basically which one which one
this one Eric once sorry I want to take
this comment down but if I want to say
it this one's a great one the one six
[ __ ] committee I think we I think the
house whatever Hunter Biden committee
that they come up with that's what it
should be called the one six [ __ ] [ __ ]
committee that's yeah that's brilliant
that's not bad so so Eric Weinstein you
you see this a lot yesterday people like
oh my God I can't believe what I'm
reading which is the same thing yeah
okay yeah it's irrelevant okay the point
is is people are reacting on the right
the same way that they did uh on
Thursday or Friday whenever the [ __ ]
vials came out right and said like oh my
God this is a [ __ ] bombshell no it
was a nothing Burger there wasn't
anything there it just proved there was
there was a huge [ __ ] there yeah there
was a huge shotgun and it revealed that
there was a protocol and process in
place when you report stuff and there's
nothing new about it and there was no
government involvement and again Joe
Biden wasn't the president and he wasn't
even elected yet so let's remember these
things as we go through because now Eric
wine she says I can't believe what I'm
reading so let's go slow the FBI's
former attorney was hired by previous
Twitter management again this is not new
in the sense that people from government
go into the private sector and their
attorneys and they're hired as attorneys
that's a thing they're good at what they
do so a private company says hey we're
going to pay you a bunch of money to
come in here because you know how to
handle this and this and this you have
experience right we feel like you're
you're good at the job so they bring
them in so this isn't crazy
controversial this is pretty standard
people go into private sector all the
time just like I'm sure Adam kinzinger
will go into the private sector once
he's done being representative so here
you have the FBI's former attorney was
hired by previous Twitter management and
was the one vetting the files to be
given to Barry Weiss and Matt haibi that
might reveal FBI collusion again
president trump it was his FBI so any
collusion that was there what is it Jim
Baker wait Jim wait wait wait you're
saying Jim Baker is Trump's FBI
uh I gotta know if he retired before
that instead of retired in 2018 so yes
so he was at the FBA now I think he's
prior because this is the whole this is
why fake games like Carter page Carter
page fights advisor Pfizer right and
whatever he was on December December
2017 is when he left office so okay so
when was when when did he start that's
what I want to know uh 2014.
started during the Obama Administration
all right I just wanna I just want to
you know make sure we're getting all the
all the Kaka mini facts straight here
right so he was still in the FBI while
Trump was President right okay so he
could have fired him just like he fired
yeah he could have fired him no I wanna
I wanna point out mine is Robin uh our
great moderator has a good one Hunter
six six caliber so
that's pretty good they're they're
everywhere I mean there's there's [ __ ]
all up in the chat folks you you pull
six cabler out of the [ __ ] oh man
that's so hard to pull out of the rock
there
um uh oh Hunter's lap [ __ ] I mean it's
just the Wang it's Wang Wednesday and
it's everywhere it's everywhere and Wang
Wednesday maybe we should change
Wednesday to Wayne Wednesday welcome and
I'm definitely calling any any committee
that the um that the house has on Hunter
Biden's laptop
mini that's right okay go ahead sorry I
didn't mean to interrupt you know it's
important news here yeah I know I
totally they're breaking groundbreaking
this is democracy this is hard-hitting
stuff Tony hard it's almost like you
know you gotta go so deep uh into the
information that you gotta really go
ahead right now yeah really thrust into
it right so he's he he's uh Eric
Weinstein has the same response everyone
else does on the right oh my God I can't
believe what I'm seeing right because
it's based on this other tweet that was
quoting Matt taibi that says Twitter's
former top Attorney James Baker was
formerly an FBI agent who passed on fake
dirt from the Hillary campaign
operatives in 2016 alleging a Secret
online portal from Russia's Alpha Bank
to Trump now attempting to shape the
Twitter files okay so hang on oh no I
don't know Lee Fang is here but that's
[ __ ] [ __ ] it wasn't fake dirt
from uh campaigns operatives and we've
already went through a trial we already
did this with Durham right is that it
was it was legitimate it was a
legitimate concern that these attorneys
from the campaign said whoa whoa whoa
this is crime
this this isn't just dirt this is crime
this is possible crime that's why they
did that and it was proven in trial they
yeah they threw it out so yeah but then
if you look and you look at the Russia
you know collusion that happened we know
it was in fact something that was real
you had Mueller the report but then you
also know that bill Barr uh had uh
caused obstruction to this story the
other the other collusion is we have a
guilty uh conviction of not just uh Ron
Paul but um Rand Paul and Mitch
McConnell a former staffer who took
[ __ ] money Russian money campaign
money foreign [ __ ] money which is
illegal as [ __ ] and siphoned it into the
Trump campaign in 2016. and that
[ __ ] is gonna go to prison so I
mean the Russian collusion was real now
not but I the thing that you're missing
there is that Aid also was pardoned
wait wait oh you're saying what you're
saying he was pardoned for a a crime
that he committed in Iowa yeah yeah and
part and Trump pardoned him I wonder if
that was to keep his [ __ ] mouth shut
about the goddamn foreign payment that
Trump knew that he got anyways you know
we go on just the fact that this guy was
pardoned but then they still got his
[ __ ] ass is amazing and and we're
standing around talking about Hunter
Biden right right so what the [ __ ] um so
this is this is all this supplemental is
is them trying to basically what they're
what they've proved here if anything
again like they proved that there was a
protocol and process in place for like
content moderation is they they've
proved that James Baker who was the
legal counsel yeah at Twitter was doing
his job by reviewing who Elon had
control over right Elon had a control
over Elon knew who was there right he
met with legal counsel he knew who they
were and you want to know why not only
in preparing for this deal and signing
off on it but when you lay off thousands
of people you have meetings with your
[ __ ] legal team to make sure that
you're not breaking any rules or laws
and when you do break the laws you have
a team that has to assess it to say okay
well if we do break the law these are
the fines are gonna have to pay and this
is how we bait that's how it all evens
out now I wanna I wanna put it in a
perspective though
because
we are giving Elon way too much credit
here even in this moment where we're
saying that he knows who James Baker is
okay Elon is not [ __ ] smart at all
um he uses he uses big words he says
them in a way that makes makes [ __ ]
idiots on the internet think he's the
the smartest person in the entire world
and they're like well you just got a lot
of money so we must be smart it ain't
like it was given to him in a silver
spoon and he stole it by not paying
taxes and taking taking [ __ ]
government money I mean you know it's on
and on with this stuff but
I think you're giving Elon way too much
credit when you use when you say he's in
a room and he is paying attention to
anyone in the room
when they're talking I mean when he's
talking when he's talking
obviously when they're talking I would
almost imagine when when elon's in a
room and he's so [ __ ] dumb that when
people are talking he just won't and
this is what he hears you know the
peanuts
that's probably what he is hearing
because he's he's he has such a [ __ ]
inflated ego yeah um at this point so so
so in summary yeah the supplement the
Twitter files supplemental mm-hmm
did not prove that there was more
collusion or suppression it proved that
Jim Baker who Elon was aware of who
works there and had seen whether he'd
listened to or not definitely met him
um
he's gonna put out there it's it you
can't tell me because here's the thing
you can't tell me that Elon buys a
company for 44 million and lays off but
here's does it meet it doesn't matter if
if the problem is James Baker and elon's
the owner sole owner of the company and
he has the ability to fire James Baker
right isn't that his [ __ ] problem
isn't the accountability on him isn't
isn't it because the cover-up really is
of Hunter Biden's [ __ ] isn't it elon's
fault it feels like to me the real story
here is that Elon Musk is responsible
responsible for the destruction of
democracy because we the people did not
get to see Hunter Biden's hog this is
ridiculous and we should call for
investigations [ __ ] committees
everywhere to investigate Elon Musk
colluding colluding with James Baker who
is a a former FBI and everyone knows the
FBI AI is is corrupt because they went
and took our they took back our
documents and Mar-A-Lago justifiably
with a search warrant and that's corrupt
as hell I I can't even it's hard to even
do I can't finish it a bit it's it's
hard it's ridiculous it's so hard it's
right it's Solid Rock oh my God there's
rock hard so hard
what a story what that is again a big
[ __ ] whopping nothing Burger the
first one the part one proved that
Republicans are obsessed with Hunter
Biden's [ __ ] and uh Twitter had a a
process to remove any pornographic
material that was non-consensual under a
government that was not Joe Biden
and additionally they proved that while
Elon knows who Jim Baker is and wants to
be like oh I just learned who the guy
was and what his involvement was that's
so crazy because here's the thing you
can't tell me that uh also
that Elon Musk couldn't get those files
and have a clear a clear process if
you're gonna say oh you had to
uh Matt taibi had to agree to certain
conditions there's going to be some
people along the way that probably I
don't know create a document that says
here are the conditions under which you
have to agree to and what you have
access to
just saying it just proves again it's a
big [ __ ] zero whopping nothing burger
and the other thing that improves is all
this [ __ ] about Hunter Biden's
laptop is all nonsense yeah because if
truly there was something on the laptop
that proved Joe Biden was some kind of
[ __ ] you know murderous dictator or
colluding with China wouldn't they have
this in one of these threads somewhere
somewhere wouldn't there be evidence
somewhere
anywhere just waiting just anywhere
anywhere did they even type the word
China in any of these threads
not yet that I've seen I'm waiting for
it though I'm waiting for it because
isn't that supposed to be the whole
[ __ ] q and on point is the China
thing I don't know [ __ ] it's it's hard
to know it's always something new I
wanna I wanna talk about one more topic
yeah
and I asked you about it this morning
I said what should we go with the title
and the thumbnail now we went with
guilty Loser yeah because that's always
an easy one right yeah yeah Trump
organization guilty on all counts guilty
[ __ ] and you're a loser but let's go to
the loser part because he lost a lot
yesterday but one place that his
endorsed candidate hand-picked candidate
lost was Georgia and you know you said
this morning when I said should we go
with the Walker angle or should we go
with the
the Trump organization angle you're like
ah Walker is irrelevant at this point so
I want to give him one I mean I'm sure
he's going to say some bonus yeah yeah
bone end of the week but but I want to
give it one last go here yeah
um because you've done some what was
that and you've done research on Walker
and dove into this stuff dude there is
way there is so much more I could have
made probably a third one if I really
wanted to but I there's like so much
nonsense but you have history you have
history yeah yeah yeah Walker's son
Christian where you're his virtual
internet room right yeah um so tell me
what is your view of the Georgia runoff
that happened yesterday and you know I
mean it's not surprising I really
thought that Warnock was gonna pull this
out I mean yeah I mean the turnout was
there and it appeared to be there the
entire time but it was definitely much
closer than I think a lot of people
wanted it to be well I mean I mean
50 point margin is closed captioning not
available
big moment for Georgia once again they
confirmed that you know they've got two
Democratic senators and keep in mind
after 2020 during sb2 for SB 202 which
is the 2021 controversial Reform Bill
which pulled out things like you can't
give people water and lime they shorten
the amount of time from nine weeks to
four weeks Republican authors that did
it were like oh well people are
exhausted and this and that for voters
and this and blah blah blah no you you
did it because four weeks would not
allow everyone the ability to vote then
not only that
but they shortened the in-person early
voting from two plus weeks to one week
so again your voter you're you're
causing uh restriction and access voter
suppression to people in Georgia and
even with those things they were still
able to pull out a win which is amazing
which is amazing because we don't have
to worry about that seat again for for
years for a handful years
now when I look at Georgia
I mean it's a it's there's a lot of
things one Herschel Walker is
incompetent uh no experience no platform
nothing there if anything he's just a
Trope of the African-American Community
um Republicans don't really care about
who was in there they just needed
another seat because for Herschel Walker
to them Herschel Walker was a vote he
was just uh someone that he could
guarantee to check off in the box and
say oh yeah we want to vote for this
thing we've got another person that we
can guaranteed get in place to push our
harmful destructive policies that is all
that Herschel Walker was for him now the
other thing was last night Christian
Walker had a Twitter spaces and I went
in there to listen under another account
that I have uh my what was that account
I was debating if I wanted to jump in or
not but I just let it play out and
listening to this play out was very
interesting because you mean what
Christian was saying right who was he
hosting the space he was hosting the
space so he had people both on the right
and the left come in and ask questions
which I think was was good to see
but I don't actually I it's Christian is
I actually don't think that Christian is
afraid of having oh someone from the
left speak now he was actually on Hassan
piker's show right right well I mean he
didn't he didn't like the videos I made
and so well right right now he's still a
snowflake but I'm I'm saying yeah yeah
um there's something to be said and
again I I I would have him on this show
and I would you know come on and eat his
lunch but so but you're saying he's
hosting the space so yeah he was
listening and talking to left right yeah
yeah some some things he answered some
things he didn't you know he was like
people got to get away from this 2020.
it was like a q a where he's answering
questions about it pretty much so he set
it up so he he explained everything from
his side of the story did you record it
is it recorded on his account I think
yeah you can oh it's still there you can
go back and listen to it so basically he
goes through and he explains the whole
backstory and he says like here's what I
knew here's when the story came out
here's what my dad's campaign said here
is what then they follow the next day
he's like just about the abortion things
it's about the abortion the secret kids
this story that story whatever the [ __ ]
they dumped on him yeah he was like I he
said he knew about his the two other
kids right and then the campaign doubled
down we're like he only knows about you
know there's only three kids and the
next day of course Daily Beast is
waiting for him to say that so they
released the fourth kid to be like look
this more abortion stories all this
stuff comes out
he said that along the way he was very
supportive up until a certain point when
the lies came in and he said he was
supportive and he would have voted
because he was like oh a Republican and
see we need that no matter what so I'm
gonna vote for my dad I'm gonna be
supportive
he said he knew some of this stuff as
well when it came to
um just knowing just a lack of
experience in some of the kids and
whatever and he said
he would watch interviews with his dad
and he was like what are you doing
you're not preparing you're not at all
ready to go for this interview and I
guess his dad was very much under the
mindset of like oh I'm an athlete and I
don't need to prepare I'm a natural born
competitor
insane I mean I mean if you're a fast
runner but what does that have to do
yeah it's it's crazy so okay I mean
because because I could probably do an
interview without much prep but I could
not I could not be a running back yeah
yeah and it's just one of those things
where so basically Christian Walker is
talking about experience and I'm like
yeah I get it that you grew up in this
terrible household and it was it was uh
very traumatizing I mean I still think
you're a shitty person
but he added some context where I'm like
okay whatever then he went and started
answering questions and people were
asking like oh would you ever go into
politics he's like no I never go into
politics I would never run I just want
to commentate on the culture and the
policies and things like that very much
Pro Ron DeSantis people were asking him
about what it took so he's he's tucked
tail and run from from Trump
yeah well no not really what he did was
he was saying I'm he kept being like I'm
an OG 2015 Trump Maga these new people
Maga are like it was kind of this like
culture infighting that he was bringing
up like these new Mega people versus the
OG Mega people right it's what I said
the other day with the um with the
protest
um in Columbus Ohio he had a bunch of
groups and they [ __ ] hate each other
like the proud boys are telling these
other people you know oh you're not
you're you're too you're being too in
you know overtly Nazi stop doing that
and then you have another group that's
pissed off and they hate Patriot front
proud boys are shouting feds feds feds
they think they're all federal agent
it's all [ __ ] weird so this is right
this is what he brings up in this whole
talk you know not only that
but I I I it's it's very hard for me to
understand how someone like Christian
Walker who is openly gay uh and part of
the eligible well he says he's not part
of the LGBT community but he is does
like men but in that it's like why would
you support a group that was Voting
against
same-sex marriage right the rights that
you would have if you wanted to get into
a relationship right uh because
obviously
the same reason that Mitch McConnell
right it doesn't make any right yeah
well that's supposed to make sense the
cruelty is the point so basically this
whole Twitter space was him trying to it
was in some ways it felt like he was
trying to Rebrand himself to be like Oh
I'm I can he's like I'm finally free I
can talk about it I can be open I can I
can actually speak out about this
because I haven't said anything since
the last video I made a couple months
ago where I went after my dad and
basically he was like my dad this this
is the videos that he's you're talking
about this is the videos that after they
found out the abortion part and the
children and he just he snapped on one
of these stories right you know the
funny part about this whole song yeah
yeah right
um because Christian Walker has an
internet presence but Herschel Walker
really did not yeah that much I mean a
little bit not a lot he did a lot of
interviews he did a lot of talks I think
he was paid for a lot of these
motivational talks where he said his
really dumb [ __ ] Patriot takes pulled up
a lot of this stuff yeah and those those
things you can I mean I know I pulled
some for my first what was that on
Herschel Walker but you could they're
literally still on YouTube right but
here's the thing here is the thing is no
one really knew the the abortion stuff
no one really knew that the the secret
kids are are the un uh the kids that he
wasn't claiming now they they knew the
stories about the the violence and the
guns because that's some sort of public
record with the violence of this well
you know he wrote he had a memoir about
his minimum stuff was out there but
nobody talked about it right but
in the the
in the act of trump convincing Herschel
Walker
to run for Senate because I believe
that's what it was
it was you can win because you're a
Heisman Trophy winner right that's yeah
that had no in the [ __ ] thing but but
he would have been known as the Heisman
Trophy winner wrote a Memoirs kind of
crazy he's a Maga but he's you know he
just he's weird but now he lives in this
space that I don't think Herschel Walker
ever wanted to live in no and it was
Trump Who convinced him to do this to
himself according according to uh to
Christian uh he called him like every
day for two months
to get here Herschel Walker Oh Christmas
called Herschel Walker like every day
for two months to get this is what he
said in the live on the yeah he sent a
tweet as well but then he also went into
a live and he was going after people
yesterday but basically at the end of it
you have a guy who probably didn't
really want to run
but was lifted up a bunch to be like hey
you're the heart of Georgia you're
Heisman you know Bulldogs this that blah
blah blah you can run run for run
Hershel run all that [ __ ] well I
mean here's the thing is is Trump you
know in his in his misunderstanding of
politics he truly did understand
um Herschel Walker and we played a video
from Thomas the villain
um Herschel Walker was the perfect
candidate for Trump to back in Georgia
per I mean he was never going to win the
the actual election but he was going to
win the primary for sure and he was
going to be the perfect candidate that
Trump needed in Georgia to basically be
the epitome of what the white tropes
that are always on black men and he is
the the absolute epitome of every single
one of those I forget I think it was
Thomas and the villain Thomas Bishop
villain Thomas Bishop Tick Tock that we
played and he did a great job of laying
it out uh on a show but
um I I think I think in Trump's
ridiculous
um you know throwing spaghetti but in
this case ketchup at the wall
um he actually did a thing where it was
the correct candidate that he wanted
right and that worked for him and it
worked for white supremacy and it worked
to move the Maga movement who gives a
[ __ ] if they won they really don't give
a [ __ ] if they win they'll just be like
oh it was stolen like in Arizona they
don't give a [ __ ] they don't care if
they win like ah was stolen I actually
won even though I'm not in office
because there's no evidence yeah um but
this is the thing but here's the good
news here's the good news I want to give
everyone because it's not just the 51
votes it really isn't just the 51 votes
I mean that may that means a lot in the
Senate because basically Joe manchin is
now handicapped he can't control the
Senate yeah um he can't be playing you
know quasi-president
um but and we have full control over the
Committees now we do not have to share
Powers Mitch McConnell over the
Committees but the most important part
is the message the message is the most
important part we have to keep sending
this [ __ ] message to these boneheads
that you're crazy you're kind of your
your [ __ ] brand of crazy
we do not want in our government we do
not want it it can be on television it
can be on podcast it can be in these
crazy spaces that you want to have but
it can't be controlling our policies and
I think that's the most important thing
that we need to keep doing day after day
after day is pounding the message and
that is why today we talked about Putin
[ __ ] his pants and Hunter Biden's
schlong because we have to we've got to
mock them you gotta mock them folks you
have to mock these people I mean you've
got Sean Spicer saying today is [ __ ]
D-Day
for why why did you see that no what is
this okay one before we go what what is
what is this John Spicer yeah I know
who's Sean Spicer yeah yeah uh
here let me let me see if I can find the
original tweet
so what was the context he's saying me
because of the runoff election yeah it's
here let me uh I mean the other the
other significant thing about this win
is that Democrats didn't lose one
incumbent in the Senate
yeah not one so this is which is right
which is very impressive because you
typically see incumbents lose right when
they're challenged
well in in a in a in a midterm like this
where there's supposed to be a red wave
okay so what is this um so these are two
screenshots from
um
of Sean Spicer that's not what I wanted
why is it doing that what the hell hang
on a second
I'll get it here
maybe not
wow how worthless am I okay
paste there's what I want
go to it now we got it into the show
they just can't I can't handle it can't
do it no okay remember today is December
7th okay December 7th 1941 okay date
yeah moving in for me boom all right so
just so you know this is what Sean
Spicer says today is right
okay okay
today is D-Day he says it only lives in
infamy if we remember and share the
story of sacrifice with the Next
Generation hashtag D now I'm sure I am
sure Sean Spicer was trying to show
today's D-Day we stormed the beaches we
[ __ ] fight it trying to tie in with
like this next step in like where the
election goes right trying to push this
idea that this is our D-Day
unfortunately uh it's not D-Day it's not
D-Day or V day yeah or it's yeah it's
it's December 7th it's the day that
Pearl Harbor was attacked in 1941. so so
he literally thought that it was
D-Day as in the beaches Omaha and and he
apologizes here why didn't he just
delete the [ __ ] thing oh maybe it did
but he might have by this time I think
people already shot him and Michael
Reagan here points out Sean D-Day is
June 6th this is Pearl Harbor day just
FYI so the former press secretary and
the gang was supposed to be a great
talking head-on is he on oan or news max
he deleted he's on one of these Trader
TV news networks who's Max I think yeah
I think yeah news it's it's a news it's
a news it's a news
um Sean Spicer the news guy doesn't even
know what's the password
if that is that's the show Spicer and go
watch out
oh [ __ ] uh his co-host is Lindsey Keith
I would bet
they know what Pearl Harbor when you
type in Sean Spicer the first result is
like where did Sean Spicer go
that's hilarious he went he went to the
86 trash bin of History
because he's a [ __ ] and doesn't know
what day Pearl Harbor and what day D-Day
is and I'm sure if you do v-day he
probably doesn't even know what the b
stands for on b day everybody everybody
listen
we provide this show every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific for two
full hours and tomorrow is Thursday you
get to vote for bone end of the week so
go to Subs subscribe to the YouTube
channel you go to the community tab you
can vote there you can also follow us on
Twitter at Tony Michaels pod you'll be
able to vote there as soon as Gabe
Sanchez posted over there uh and also
download every single episode Apple
Spotify Google
until tomorrow because there is a
tomorrow tomorrow's Thursday you
you
and I'm sure there'll be plenty of [ __ ]
to talk about tomorrow oh yeah maybe
some more Hunter Biden [ __ ] talk I don't
know uh everyone thanks thanks for
giving us your descriptions of Hunter
mine's huge dick today it was um very
amusing and I'm sure the Republicans
will love all your nicknames and
remember before we go any committee from
here henceforth about Hunter Biden's
laptop or anything Hunter Biden in the
Republican house is known as the [ __ ]
committee ever
until tomorrow same time same place same
[ __ ] stories Elon whoosh Surf's Up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon